not only one but two news from the DC
extended universe terminated this week's
headlines on one hand it was announced
that there will be a second part of
Aquaman with Chase Momoa on the other
hand fans can expect a har spinoff
called the trench whether James Rahon
will return as producer for both movies
is still uncertain but due to the
success of Aquaman highly likely more
interesting is the question what Aquaman
2 will be all about that Jason Momoa and
Amber Heard will return is considered
certain and also the fact that Will and
Black Manta will play a role again was
already teased in the credits of the
first part through the horror spin of
the trench we know even less information
except that the tile giving creatures of
the first part will play a larger role
this time according to a couple of
sources
Aquaman and Mara will also have to deal
with a completely new beast of the DC
Universe there is no information on the
production and cinema lounge dead yet
however we'll keep you up to date as
usual only last month the return of the
card series Breaking Bad including the
original cast of Brad Cranston and Aaron
Paul in the form of a feature film was
announced originally the series was
produced by US broadcaster AMC and led
to release on Netflix however in the
upcoming movie it will be the other way
around this would have an advantage
especially for non American fans while
the series was first broadcast on US
television and then made available to
everyone on Netflix Netflix own
production would be immediately
available to all fans worldwide after
its release an official statement that
Netflix has secured these rights is
still missing but the usually very well
informed Hollywood Reporter is pretty
sure as reported Breaking Bad creator
Vince Gilligan will take over the
directing part his lead actor Brad
Krantz and said the following about the
film we have a great story that will end
the storylines that have been left
unfinished an official release date is
not yet known but you will surely hear
more about Breaking Bad
many fans of the Terminator series have
counted on a Super Bowl trailer for the
reboot and were deeply disappointed
instead James Cameron announced the
title and some interesting details this
week the Terminator reboot will be
called dark fate and Arnold
Schwarzenegger will play a role as well
according to Cameron Schwarzenegger is
supposed to return and be really evil so
we will experience a completely new
Terminator that we haven't seen before
by the way the film is supposed to tie
in directly with Terminator 2 from 1991
and Linda Hamilton in her iconic role as
Sarah Connor will also be part of it
again in addition it was revealed that
the film will be set in Mexico of course
we still hope for a trailer and we
probably can expect it soon after all
the release set is already set for
November 1st 2019 an exciting crossover
animated film is about to happen
according to sci-fi wire the official
title is supposed to be Batman versus
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and the
published picture indicates that the
popular comic characters will not fight
against each other but side-by-side
against one or more villains the
inspiration is a 2015 published comic
template in which the Ninja Turtle
suddenly end up in Gotham City through a
dimensional portal and fight alongside
Batman against Joker and ko whether the
filming will be based on the comic
template one-to-one is not sure yet
however at least the dubbing actors are
highly presentable Troy Baker known from
the video game The Last of Us will play
both Batman and Joker in a vision the
penguin will be spoken by the voice of
the American spongebob when and where
Batman versus Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles will be released is
unfortunately not known so far it could
be over soon with friends Riverdale and
the Big Bang Theory on Netflix at least
some fans aspectus after a lot of Disney
content was removed by Netflix bit by
bit due to a planned Disney on streaming
service called his name Plus in addition
Warner Brothers is planning its own
streaming service as one a giant Kevin
Bradley recently announced according to
him sharing content is not a good model
unfortunately there is hardly any chance
to extend the contract because sooner or
later the one accountant will know
you license on external platforms like
Amazon Prime or Netflix but will be
offered exclusively on wanna streaming
portal
plenty of indication suggests that
Captain America will probably have no
future in the Marvel Universe
after Avengers and game since actor
Chris Evans is already working on a new
franchise the science fiction movie
called infinite as the to reliable
sources variety and that lab report
infinite is supposed to be the adaption
of a book by the Eric microns and
revolves around a secret society whose
members are all aware of their previous
lives so does Chris Evans whose
character wants to become a member of
this conspired community deadline also
means to know that paramount is already
working behind the scenes on sequels if
the first part achieves the expected
success and exactly this new franchise
supports the suspicions that Chris Evans
won't be back on camera as Captain
America after avengers endgame so if
everything works out according to the
plan infinite will be in the cinemas by
mid 2020 although there is no official
release date yet
[Music]